in this video I want to show you how to
go about calculating the energy yield
that you get for a fatty acid that has
an even number of carbons so for example
we have an 18 carbon fatty acid before
we can begin to break it down via beta
oxidation we need to turn that 18 carbon
fatty acid into an 18 carbon acyl Co a
once we have that activated fatty acid
the a so Co a this a so Co a can go
through beta oxidation so I've drawn
here 18 carbons now this is representing
the soakaway itself so how many rounds
of beta oxidation will this thing go
through well the simple way to figure
that out is draw out all these carbons
in 18 different carbons and clip off two
at a time and the reason why is because
each round of beta oxidation clips off
and acetyl co a right which is two
carbons so this would be 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
rounds of beta oxidation now if that's
eight rounds of beta oxidation
how many acetyl co is we actually make 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 2 carbon molecules which
is 9 acetyl co is cool so now these are
Co Co ways can go through the Krebs
cycle so what I've drawn here is that if
we have an 18 carbon a so CO a and it
goes through 8 cycles of beta oxidation
then we're going to have to add 1 F ad 1
nad plus and 1 coenzyme a for every
cycle of beta oxidation so because each
one one of these is used up in each
cycle so we're going to have 8 f ad a
nad fusses and 8 coenzyme a is used up
one for each of the cycles of beta
oxidation now when that happens we
create nine acetyl co a z' and then how
many nadh and fadh2 is we make well
those these come from the rounds of beta
oxidation themselves so we're going to
have a
nad HS and eight fadh2s these AF IDs are
reduced to these a fadh2s and these a
nad pluses were reduced to these eight
NADH is so now these things can go to
the electron transport chain
but this Sirocco a leave the acetyl co a
is go to the TCA cycle or the krebs
cycle and when they go to the Krebs
cycle each acetyl co a goes through the
kreb cycle once and yields three nadh
--is one fadh2 and one GTP so now that's
four that's four one acetyl co a we have
nine so we're going to multiply these
values by nine and when we do that we
get 27 nadh --is nine fadh2s and nine
GTP's but now we also have to basically
what we're doing here is we're totalling
all these nadh and fadh2 s and GDPs that
we have because they're all valued at
some sort of energy so these over here
these nadh and fadh2 s right we're going
to add them right there so we have a
NADH s eight fadh2s so if we total this
all up we have 35 NADH s total 17 fadh2s
and 9g gps now all of these have a
particular ATP value which i've drawn
here this is their ATP value
so these NADH s are valued at 2.5 each
so that's if you were to multiply 35
times 2 and 1/2 you should get 87 point
5 and then 17 times 1 and 1/2 is twenty
five point five and then of course the 9
gtp they're all valued at 1 so if you
add these all up you'll get a gross
value of 122 ATP now you net only 120
ATP now why is that the reason why is
because we have to subtract two for the
activation step in this case I asked
about breaking down an even-numbered
fatty acid right into for energy but I
asked for a fatty acid in particular
this step taking this fatty acid and
activating it to an acyl Kawai this
costs you
two atps you have to subtract to ATP
there so that's what's what's going on
there
however if I had asked you instead for
you know to calculate the energy for an
18 carbon a so Co a you wouldn't stuff
subtract this number here because the
end the thing was already activated so
you would not subtract to oops not
subtract subtract to ATP if you had been
asked for an 18 carbon a so go away
because an a so CO a is already
activated right so you wouldn't have to
worry about that activation step so you
would just you would actually met 122
ATP right but that's only if you started
off with an ASIC away
I hope that video was helpful and thank
you for watching